we're talking about the math of crime
crime yeah for people who don't know you
you know you're a proper mathematician
yeah and we're really getting into your
research yeah we're gonna in fact even
look at a paper that I've done with my
PhD students oh yes I am a real person
this is your this is your everyday yeah
yeah one of the things that's important
to know about crime or terrorism things
like that
is when it's going to happen there's a
bit of old maths that kind of helps us
start off understanding that and that's
something called the Poisson
distribution named after a guy called
paysanne fish I don't think they were
though some of my students call it the
fish distribution which is mm-hmm but
the main point about participation um
and its first practical application was
looking in the Prussian army there were
lots of soldiers who are dying from
being kicked by horses over a number of
years father owned horse by their owner
horses yeah and was his objecting to
being used as an army horse perhaps and
so there was one guy called Otto good
wits in 1898 he was tasked with looking
into how frequently these horse attacks
that were having these horse kick
attacks were happening all the day cause
it's they're more dramatic okay I know
it does and I I'm sorry and it's
actually quite soothing the point is is
that I like to think anyway horse kicks
are generally independent right horse's
neck sort of collude with each other and
decides that they are all going to kick
up a ruckus on a particular day so if
you look at a timeline of instance then
you would sort of expect your instance
your horse kick instance to be kind of
randomly distributed across this this
thing so maybe you have a couple very
quickly after each other but what that
means that you can do is if you take a
time interval so set a number of years
perhaps and you look at the chances of a
particular number of instance in that
interval then it follows this really
nice neat distribution which tooks like
this and this is called this is your
probability and this is your number of
instance and this is your price on
distribution so that means that there's
an average number of instance that you
expect in a year
say and that average number of instance
is the most likely thing to occur that
has the highest probability of all so it
might mean that you know in 1890 you
only have you know one instant perhaps
and then in 1891 you have a huge number
of instance and but also very low
probability but that most years you're
going to expect to have something around
the average rate of instant it means
that you can start looking at the time
between different events and you'd start
coming up with sort of a susceptibility
for events but there's one really
crucial thing that this stuff is missing
the Poisson distribution is missing
which is that events and crime and
terror attacks and things like that
they're not completely independent so if
one happens the chances of another one
happening very soon after really
increase and the price of distribution
can't take that into account so the
first people to look at events that
weren't completely independent were
scientists who are studying earthquakes
now you could say that perhaps
earthquakes were random were completely
random and Poisson distributed so each
earthquake was independent of every
other
but the thing is is that if you have one
earthquake you're going to be really
like to have aftershocks right say a
series of earthquakes in the same place
in quick succession of one mother
continual average lapse or keeping
everyone knows scientists and math
tutors and developed something called
Hawkes process which I think won't named
after Hawkes actually so they came up
with something called the Hawkes process
which takes into account the fact that
events aren't completely independent of
one another so instead if you're looking
at earthquake you'd expect to have
something much more likely one
earthquake happened and then you'd
expect a few more smaller earthquakes to
happen within a really short space of
time and then perhaps you'd go a little
while you'd have one with no aftershocks
and then another but with another few
sort of aftershocks tagged on quite
quickly afterwards I mean things kind of
take a bit more of this pattern but the
thing that's nice is that
well nice probably isn't the right word
but is that crime follows the same
pattern so if you take burglaries for
example anybody who's been burgled all
know that your chance of being burgled
again within a really short space of
time hugely increases this is something
called repeat victimization and the
reason is is that burglars get to know
the layout of your house they get to
know and where you keep your valuables
they get to know all sorts of things
about your local area so your chance of
being and burgled again increases but so
does your neighbors and your neighbors
neighbors and your neighbors neighbors
neighbors enable and so on as you go
along down the street this Hawkes
process then of seeing events is
connected in time means that you can
then model what happens with burglary
statistically it goes beyond just sort
of saying oh well you know obviously
that happens because you're actually
able to describe it and capture it using
numbers and using equations and as soon
as you can do that then you can start
actually implementing genuine strategies
back into the real world so for example
this is a paper that I wrote with my one
of my PhD students and this Lucas looks
at a very similar story about attacks
from the IRA in Northern Ireland and you
can see here this is a this is that the
events as they go along so this is
really similar to this graph here so
you'll have one big event and then you
have a sort of cluster of events of
and then a gap for a little while and
then another cluster of events going
through but what this means knowing that
there's this model that sits behind the
scenes is that you can actually assign
numbers there's a there's a proper
equation for this so you have your kind
of background rate so this is know that
four symbols oh it's a lambda Greek
lambda and then that's mu and another
Greek letter and so this one here this
you're going to be talking about your
intensity of attacks how likely is for
an event to occur within a short space
time so you have some sort of a
background rate so this is like your
randomness because there is still some
element of complete randomness in this
but then every time an event happens you
have a little kick so your chances of
another event get a little little boost
right and that's what this thing here
does and but then finally this boost it
doesn't last for very long so it looks
like this hmmm so your your little kick
your chance of another event happening
boosts up and then dies away quite
quickly in time you're effectively
you're summing over all of the incidents
that have happened in the past and
you're working out your kick from every
possible incident when a house gets
burgled or a bombing happens or anything
like that numbers are being fed into
equations that tell us what yeah well so
they tell us they tell us that they
capture sort of the process that's going
on behind the scenes but they do it in a
way that that sort of free from emotion
and I'm free from hand waviness so if
you apply this to something like the
troubles in Northern Ireland and the
frequency of IRA incidents there were
five actual different phases of attacks
and you can see here with this equation
the different values of these different
parameters at different points
throughout the process
they've got mu there k naught the boosts
there and Omega which is how quickly
things died away back down to normal and
what's really interesting about this is
that this allows you to come up with a
comparison between different processes
or different stages in a conflict and
actually to quantify it hello is this
all hindsight or does this give like
predictive powers or assists of
something you apply afterwards ago yeah
I think it's nice yeah well so this
example
respective but what I think is really
exciting about these ideas that you can
also apply them in real time so with
burglary in particular if you're just
looking at how the past influences the
present and will influence the future
which this allows you to do by talking
about intensity and susceptibility of
burglaries what that means is that in
real time you can pick up on a
particular area or even a particular
street that is more likely to be the
center of our burglary hotspot going
forward in time by using these methods
so there's a company in America called
pred poll who were the first to take
these equations and wrap it up neatly
into sort of an iPad app effectively so
that they can give it to different
police forces across the US and the
police forces will then get a printout
on basically a map with like a red
square saying here is where is most
likely to be victims of burglary or car
theft tonight so just by looking at
these just these really simple equations
putting in the numbers of the system and
reacting to what the math tells you
they've reduced burglary by up to 32% in
certain areas of the states it's like a
pre crimes yeah it is yeah yeah yeah
predictive policing that's what they
call it yeah
thanks to audible.com for supporting
today's episode audible has thousands
and thousands of titles in stock and
they're bound to have something you'll
enjoy and among them is the mathematics
of love by Hanna Frey who you've just
been watching now I've got Hanna's book
he is my dead tree version but I think
an audiobooks even better because you
can enjoy it on the go such as like in
your car or walking the dog or more
importantly you can hear it read by Hera
herself have you ever wondered why we're
all so obsessed with how hot a person is
it's always really interesting to hear
an audio book read by the author his or
her self and I know Hanna spent a lot of
time in the studio doing it so I'm sure
she'd appreciate it as well if you'd
like to give audible a try and I
recommend it I use it all the time go to
audible.com slash numberphile that way
they know you came from here and when
you're there you can then join for a
30-day free trial and why not make
Hanna's the mathematics of love your
first download so as the authorities get
smarter and the police get smarter and
start using mathematics to you know
fight crime could criminals start using
mathematics to plan crime well I hope
not and I hope not